the Joe Rogan experience and it happened
on thriller too you know I mean I
because of American Werewolf when
Michael came to John Landis to do
thriller you know he'd like American
World when he wanted to do he wanted it
to be a short film you didn't want to
call it a music video mm-hmm and John
contacted me and said you know Michael
Jackson wants to do this American
Werewolf like music video you know for
the song thriller which I hadn't heard
and it was like you know Michael Jackson
little Michael Jackson Andy Jackson 5
min yeah you know he's not called that
anymore you know and so he goes Johnson
I'll send you a kiss at it listen to it
and get some ideas you know so I and
this was when we had the Walkman I think
you know and yeah I'd listen to it with
one I had another one that I would like
like pre associated ideas when I was
listening you know and you know it was
like I thought well these we came up the
idea doing these jambe dancers and and I
said well you know I'm sure you're gonna
hire the dancers way in advance so they
can learn the dance and stuff and he
goes no they they they're they only need
a couple of days so they hired him like
three days before we filmed anyway I
can't that doesn't give me time to take
life masks and do all the stuff that I
would do and these zombies would be
really cool you know so I said how about
if the first time is you see are like me
and my crew because we already have life
masks we can start those today and we
can spin the time and making some cool
and so I'm in thriller coming out of a
crypt like this you know and all my crew
basically are the first guys that come
out of the ground and break their
windows but the dancers I said I'll
figure out a way we can do them and I
because I had a number of life masks of
different people and small medium and
large male small medium large female and
we sculpted we kept pieces we called
like bandit masks they were kind of like
this around this area like well I
abandoned you know run yeah it's like a
raccoon mouse yeah and it didn't have
the nose on it because you know
proportionally you could get away with
more mm-hmm
so we had different sculptures of small
medium large male small me on are female
that we have to say okay you're a medium
male number two and we made these big
teeth that we could pop in their mouths
and put some danger lining material and
fit them so the dancer makeups were not
as good as the Murphy
but Michael in the upper left-hand
corner that one Jamie were the eyes yeah
look at that like that was excellent and
again we kept it that way when what
happened is the Dom bees after that
everybody was just doing pieces like
this I only did it like that because of
limitations I had in honey but that was
I mean that was a rather really quick
job and very little money thriller was
very little money for me it turned I
mean they spent the money they had a lot
of cameras in the last winter filming
but it
I was working day and night every day
the way to get this stuff done and John
then surprised me with the making of
stroller on the day that Michael was
coming out for us to take his life
masked and make a cast of his face he
goes oh there's a camera crew here a
couple cameras saying what are you
talking about he goes I want to do a
making-of and I go I was gonna no no
it's like it always looks horrifying to
see if some of you have a life mask
taken Brian and ICO I don't need and
Michael's really shy I don't need we
don't need this yeah I don't I don't
want this he goes shut up we're doing it
you know it's like [ __ ] you know I'm not
happy about it but then so many people
have come up to me yeah and who are
makeup artists now and go the reason I'm
a makeup artist because I saw the making
of thriller and inspired me that to do
this you know and my stock answer is
you've thought that if this ad I could
do it I can do it there was a time where
music videos were a new thing and then
thriller changed what a music video is
it was so huge it was a a world premiere
event that was on MTV and it's so hard
for kids today to understand what that
means but we were all like gathered
around the TV waiting for the Michael
Jackson Thriller world premiere and it
premiered and it changed what a music
video is yeah then all of a sudden it
became this film and it was really cool
cuz like Michael Jackson was this sweet
guy and he's on a date with this
beautiful girl and and next thing you
know he's a [ __ ] werecat or whatever
he was was that supposed to be fat like
well yeah I I he wanted to be a werewolf
doesn't that you know I don't think he
should be a werewolf and I thought
something feline would be fit him better
in
and I originally did a like a black
panther and then I was afraid of the
Black Panther you know that I didn't
want him to be associated with a Black
Panthers you know what I mean the
political yeah yeah so I then became
more of fantasy I gave it longer hair
and like white Steve you find his
transformation to the cat because it was
reminiscent in somewhat of a mirror of
American Werewolf but cool and unique in
its own way I think oh we didn't we
didn't have the time to yeah I wasn't
sure what it was I was like it's not a
cat isn't a werewolf is it
yeah well all the world was sometimes
people call the cat eyes they yeah I
just you know thought it was cool
looking you know it was definitely cool
looking whatever it was but you know
what happened I mean I thriller was like
work work work work working and
originally it was going to be my my crew
were going to be the guys that do the
makeups and they were all non-union and
it at the last minute became a union
production so I had to hire Union makeup
artist and there were men yet to do the
dancers and many of them were people I
didn't know and there weren't a lot of
people that were good at this stuff
hmm yeah that's gonna give me a little
bladders in his hand there's actually an
American Werewolf hand in here at one
point I think oh really
yeah you know leftover heads yeah that's
a nail growing thing was from the
American Werewolf and then you did a
similar thing with the ears and he had
the whiskers yeah yeah it's like yeah
it's before his hair grows
yeah silly but when you look at that
like what is that yeah is that a cat
whatever it is it's cool yeah but he the
it was an amazing experience because I
you know I was like I was really
stressed out the day that we were
filming the dancers and that was I had
to make up Michael as a zombie I had a
number of makeup er so I didn't even
know and work before with before they
were doing other zombies and I'm running
through trailers going no no no like
this you know I've been making up
Michael and it's like oh man and we were
filming in Vernon downtown Los Angeles
and next to the former John Meatpacking
place and they just slaughtered the
animals and it had this weird smell in
the process and then the dance started
and I all of a sudden it just like this
wave went over me of just the stress
went away and I just was looking at what
was having in front of me and it was
going oh my god look at this you know
and people would pay money to see this
and I kept this is you know I saw this
roller dance happening when it was you
know four
first time there you know when it was
being filmed how many times did they
shoot it not that many I don't think but
there I think there was six cameras on
you know the whole street you know
friend that was filled with cameras and
but the other thing that was so cool
about it that was one of the dancer
makeups that Michael when we were doing
in pre-production Michael did a a Motown
special that was on television where he
moon walked for the first time and
nobody had seen the moonwalk and I
didn't see it I was busy working and but
one of my crew who went home at night
and it recorded it and he goes you're
not gonna believe this is the same kid
that was in her makeup chair the other
day because Michael is very shy as well
really meek and quiet in person and he's
so dynamic on stage you know and and it
was he's like two different people I
mean when Michaels performing he's
incredible you know now he was a and I
mean to say he was unique is the biggest
understatement in the history of the
world yeah but this whole scene with him
when he becomes a zombie was so bizarre
to like even the dancing was so strange
you know it was cool though he's really
cool and to see it live for the first
time you know out in the cold with it
they don't do anything like this anymore
I mean really it doesn't happen
[Applause]